so let's say you're the leader of a
country or you want to be one in the
future
you've grown sick of all these checks
and balances and limits of power and
being held accountable because of the
simple fact now you want more power
because we're more power cost more money
more freedom of moving basically you
just want to bring back the good old
days of kings and queens in the royalty
that comes with it but unfortunately
today what crowds and the working class
having more power and influence than
ever it looks like you might be at their
mercy unless you know how to control the
population of course we need to learn
how to maneuver around the population to
get them to submit to our rule without
them ever even realizing it we need to
learn how to be the puppet master and
what better example to learn how to
master the skill from than the world's
second greatest superpower China voices
like these from Chinese citizens are
very rare people who are willing to
speak out about the government's
attempts to control news about the
deadly to accounts or messages like
these calling for free speech are
quickly scrubbed from the internet or
videos like this
[Music]
posted online one day but gone the next
mission opening a Holland go where
there's a little meeting wada presumably
those are sheltered what you want
someone hoping you the enemy of the
states is information after all all of
our opinions decisions and sentiments
are based on the information we have
available to us therefore it only makes
sense that if you control the flow of
information you control the population
that's why controlling the narrative is
so important to China but it is my
experience that when the people ask
questions that are not in their own best
interest they should simply be told to
keep their minds on their labor and
leave matters of the state to this state
and since we live in the age of
information the best medium to control
the narrative is of course the Internet
controlling the Internet is so important
to China that not only do they have an
entire division of the government
dedicated to it but they have an entire
industry of Auditors as they like to
call it
that's absolutely booming combine that
with the infamous Great Firewall of
China that blocks all major Western
social media and search platforms like
all Google Apps all Facebook apps
YouTube WordPress blogger being and much
more and replaces them with government
control alternatives China is the king
of censorship the researchers I
mentioned before called the Great
Firewall the largest selective
suppression of human communication in
the recorded history of any country but
here's where you run into a problem if
you're too aggressive with censorship
obviously blocking content or certain
words or phrases during ordinary people
in prison for talking bad about the
government on top of the many
journalists that you've already thrown
in prison it will eventually backfire
people will wonder why you're trying so
hard to censor a certain topic or events
is it really that big of a threat to the
state hmm maybe the government isn't as
strong as I thought it was which will
inevitably lead to your downfall that's
why we need to be a bit more sly with
our censorship to not be so obvious
about it allow people to criticize the
government to give them the illusion of
free speech but the moment people start
mobilizing their communities for
protests or rallies to take action
those criticisms orally start calling
out specific government officials then
crush them the troops have been firing
indiscriminately indeed it was hard at
times to grasp that this army was
launching into an unarmed civilian
population as if charging into battle
with the strategy alone you killed three
birds with one stone
your subjects have the illusion that
they can voice their opinion you prevent
any actual freedom of speech from
occurring and since you control the
internet providers in your country and
monitor everything people do online
already you get to monitor your subjects
needs wants and opinions basically you
get to check the pulse of your
population instead of just censoring
things online that you don't like you
can use the very clever Chinese tactic
of flooding keep the unfavorable news
articles online but flood the search
results and comets with conflicting
information and opinions to create an
ocean of contradictions in the average
citizen would think the facts are just
to money too complicated to ever know
the truth instead of outright blocking
websites use people's impatience to your
advantage make the website a little bit
slower to load blog a website for only a
small portion of the population oh
there's a protest going on you say make
your government-run chat app WeChat lag
in that area
the goal of this is not to stop the
spread of information but to slow it
down to where the average citizen will
be too impatient to wait it out this is
called friction it's both harder to see
happening and scary effective but even
if you're able to master the art of
controlling the narrative it would be
hopeless without the next piece of the
puzzle
[Music]
we just talked about some pretty drastic
measures in the eyes of the populace
systematic censorship throwing
journalists in prison shutting down
protests and rallies how have people not
gotten up in arms already how did this
seven worth we bring the multi-billion
dollar MBA down to their knees asking
for the Lord I mean China's forgiveness
why does Marvel enthusiastically censor
their movies for the Chinese market one
word leverage if you're a US company and
you want access to China's 1.4 billion
people to sell - you're gonna have to
kiss the ring you're talking about a
one-party state that has the ability to
let you in to expel you to make you rich
China is able to block such powerful and
useful websites like Google and Facebook
because they offer Chinese startups the
incentive of less competition and the
Chinese population and beginning much or
less a similar app that's catered to
their culture and its citizens are put
in a similar position sure we don't have
too much freedom of speech and the
government is watching us 24/7 but
things have gotten so much better over
the years that's not too bad sure things
could be better but Howard GDP per
capita average income and overall
quality of life has improved so much
over the last 25 years that you know
what it's okay for now if you want to
heavily control your population if you
want to be the puppet master you better
have some leverage over your subjects
and give them a good reason to comply
because using straight-up fear causes
too many problems these days if you
don't you can kiss your power and
goodbye and if you're thinking to
yourself but Jake man this sounds kind
of hard
- that our wordplay yeah that's kind of
the point because if it was easy every
country every leader would do it
remember the long term vision we're here
to build an empire up subservient
subjects it will take some time so take
a deep breath and let's move on to the
next key into the hearts and minds of
the population
people always say they want massive
change hell though even campaign behind
people who shout at the rooftops for
massive change but in reality people
despise change especially when it
affects them personally therefore if you
want to implement these massive moves
like systematic censorship throwing
journalism prisons shutting down
protests and rallies everything that
we've been talking about instead of
trying to do it all at once you want to
take it inch by inch push people to the
very edge of what they're comfortable
with and then go just an inch past that
then hold back create the illusion that
this is just a small but necessary
change that's in their best interest
once this becomes the public's new
normal rinse and repeat the process and
before you know it you push people miles
past where they were without them even
noticing how far they've strayed things
get to terrible places one tiny step at
a time if I encroach on you and I'm
sophisticated about it I'm gonna
encroach right to the point where you
stop start the protest then I'm gonna
stop and I'm gonna wait then you're
gonna calm down then I'm gonna encroach
again and I'm just gonna do that forever
start with just a teeny tiny bit of
censorship claim how many lies it was
saved how much better society will be
because of it after this level a
censorship becomes a new normal move for
another inch of censorship then gain
control a little bit more of the
narrative and before you know it you're
on the same level of China do the same
thing with surveillance slowly add more
cameras to the streets frame
surveillance as not a dystopian tool for
Big Brother to watch over you but ask
the temptress of bleeding-edge
convenience like they do in Shenzhen the
silicon valley of hardware try to
jaywalk in certain parts of Shenzhen and
the government's facial recognition will
spot you there's even a board of shame
showing the faces of recent offenders
it's already started tracking behavior
as part of a plan to rank citizens and
measure how good and obedient they are
even though the strategy takes more time
the benefit to it is that your
intentions fly right under the nose of
the public if you do a rites no
retaliation no protest just compliance
but if you really want to move more like
a few miles at a time instead of just a
few inches there's one big exception to
this rule there's a saying in politics
never let a good crisis go to waste
[Music]
crisis are a goldmine after 9/11 the
u.s. population and even people in the
government were put into absolute fear
and all they wanted was for someone to
stand up and do something about it to
make them feel safe again
and the man that took advantage of this
none other than Dick Cheney and so
everybody just went I don't care who
does it stop it and they said this to
Dick Cheney which is a historic mistake
but cuz date Dick Cheney knows how
government works dick was a pretty
clever guy you could even go as far as
calling him a master at this game of
power see he uses cry for help this
feeling of fear to put together the most
intruding surveillance programs ever
seen in US history is it pathetic
compared to China's yes but compared to
where the US was before 9/11 it was a
huge accomplishment in a prime example
of how you should take advantage of a
crisis but dick didn't stop there he
wanted to note this crisis for
everything it's got and on top of his
surveillance accomplishments he profited
very handsomely after the war on terror
leaving office as the most powerful vice
president in US history now whether or
not you like him or dislike him is
irrelevant the lesson is if you want to
tighten your grip on your population
faster don't let a crisis go to waste is
when we become fearful we become
vulnerable to anyone who promises they
will make things better even if they
have no ability to make things better
even if they will actively make things
worse but if they tell you that they'll
make things better and you believe them
in a moment of fear that that typically
leads to unfortunate outcomes and now
for the final and arguably most
important piece of the puzzle
the culture of a society is the root of
everything the culture of your
population is what's gonna allow or
prevent you from gaining the power you
need see what people don't understand is
that it's not the laws and institutions
that influence the crowd
it's the crowds culture that allows for
the laws to be passed in the first place
and for the institutions to act as they
do or in other words if you want to be
the puppet master you have to create a
culture that is receptive to your
published strings this is by far the
hardest part of the equation because
changing a culture takes time which can
be sped up with the crisis but you get
the points luckily for China their
culture has already been rooted in the
family for generations where elders are
supposed to be respected and followed
without question
compare that to Western culture that's
more rooted in the individual instead of
the family this leaves the Chinese
government in the perfect position to
fill that void as the nation's elder for
its children to follow without question
it's what Chinese companies are not only
willing but want to help out the
government with censorship and
surveillance engines in the noodle soup
all done some good high-end they thought
was a name we hope we tsamina just
fascinating that culture is what makes
them feel pride when they do it if
you're able to solve this problem of
culture everything will fall into place
with so much less friction because all
the power censorship surveillance
leverage and publish strings will just
be an inevitable downstream of the
culture you created
welcome to the watch dead-end Club and
if you enjoyed this more controversial
video essay please consider subscribing
because it's free and you can dislike an
unsub whenever you want because I make
video essays like this every single week
on the most provocative stuff in the
world business if you want to support
this channel financially completely
optional by the way being that you're
stuck at home right now for obvious
reasons you might as well make the most
Alvah time by learning how to land every
mobile job so that in situations like
this you are perfectly fine that is how
I got my start in this whole make money
online thing by landing a $40 per hour
remote rub tough job and I firmly
believe well and I firmly believe that
this is the most practical path out
there compared to all the other methods
being promoted so if you think that
would interest you check out the course
I made on how to go remote with the link
in the video description for a very
accessible price that's all I got for
this video thank you so much for
watching you've been awesome
I've been Jake and I'll see you guys in
the next one
[Music]